was Kanye actually is a classic comic
book superhero villain
so the onset of his Insanity you know
where it really really began prior to
this
uh the death of his mom yeah like every
[ __ ] comic book superhero or villain
there is that one tragic moment that
they have where that turns them evil or
it turns them good yeah the death of his
mom turned him this way right right so
in five four three two one Hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast I'm not sure if
Halloween is going to pass here soon or
if it's already most likely it's going
to pass if I put this out on Sunday yeah
did you when you went to church
did you guys used to have Hallelujah
nights
Hallelujah
dude let me tell you something man
that's like the corniest thing that
every Korean Church did yeah we never do
a Halloween we appraised a g just
because that's a terrible work
Hallelujah
we we stood there for sure like do the
trick-or-treating
uh without the devil right
but then like we got this really like
liberal Theology and leaning Pastor come
in right and he was like Hey like our
really big church was in the middle of
the ghetto in Tacoma yeah so he's like
we need to open these doors and invite
the neighborhood to the church on these
Hallelujah nights or they mean nothing
they're just for us right so they went
out to the neighborhood put out flyers
asked them to come play games we'll have
all this Carnival [ __ ] and whatever like
I mean obviously the brochure didn't say
[ __ ] but
but yeah like all the neighborhood
people showed up right this
is a devil costume
[Laughter]
what's up [ __ ]
what y'all know about this is the devil
[ __ ]
that's hella funny dude that's the only
way we could get candy that night
because it'd be like Halloween you go to
church turn off the lights don't answer
the door when people ring we don't have
any candy put up a sign says no candy
yeah yeah you had to be that family dude
dude we were that family too because we
weren't there on Halloween we were at
the church yeah we would do I don't know
if this is a proper when I think about
it now what a weird way to say this they
go oh on Hallelujah night we're gonna do
a lockdown and I'm like first of all
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it was a lock-in
they're locked down from the table so if
you guys have never attended a Korean
church and I'm not sure if they do this
at non-korean churches as well but
instead of doing Halloween right because
I don't know what the the history of
Halloween is but it had to do with like
witches and [ __ ] right yeah it was like
um when they were like killing all those
Richard the The Witch Trials all that
[ __ ] like accusing one another being
witches and [ __ ] like I guess one of the
stories is
um I mean the folklore around the towns
would be like yeah if
um you don't give me a tree get a treat
like which will kill you or some [ __ ]
like that I have no clue but it's one of
those [ __ ] stuff it's so it started
with like witchcraft yeah like 200 years
ago or some [ __ ] I used to find it so
funny back in the day when I remember
like in history class they said that
they used to have these really weird and
archaic ways to see if you could find
out if this person was a witch or not
and they were like okay this is what's
gonna happen
we're gonna [ __ ] burn you alive yeah
and if you live
yeah
and if you die then you're innocent
we're gonna put rocks around your ankles
oh yeah I'm gonna throw you in a lake
and did you float to the top clearly
you're a witch
oh my God whoever made up these rolls is
so [ __ ] up dude this is like the time
when like towns were just so isolated
like people had to rule themselves
there's not no real form of governance
yeah it was just like the original
colonies yeah they didn't have [ __ ]
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] dude you
think cancel culture is bad
can you imagine Twitter during the Salem
Witch Trials like this [ __ ] Brittany is
a witch
dude freaking we used to have these
Hallelujah nights were like I just
explain it again uh instead of going out
into the neighborhood and
trick-or-treating and celebrating
Halloween which is you know connection
to the devil
um a lot of Korean churches would do
these Hallelujah nights but we would
have these games and they would set it
up like a carnival yeah so we would have
different like it was a really great
bonding experience right we did a lot of
fun [ __ ] and to be honest with you the
candy was probably better here than you
would get anywhere else it was like
legit [ __ ] we would walk away with bags
of king size a hundred percent and so we
would do all these games we would do
prayers and that night we would have a
lock-in where we would just sleep but
nobody would really sleep yeah we would
just you know eat ramen and just [ __ ]
around yep yeah all night I remember uh
so in one of these lock-ins this one
Hallelujah I don't know why the [ __ ] I
did this [ __ ] but you know like when
girls play fight right sometimes when
girls play a fight they assume that just
because you're a guy you don't feel pain
you're like you just don't feel pain you
just nut check dudes hit them as hard as
you want it's okay he's a [ __ ] guy so
this girl had the bright idea that she
would take a wet towel [ __ ] whip me
oh dude so she whipped the [ __ ] out of
did it breakskin uh it hurts so and not
only did she do it once she did it
multiple times and listen I don't give a
[ __ ] how cute you are right remember
when she's older me so I didn't find her
attractive anyways yeah I just thought
of this girl was trying to bully me I
was like let me tell you something I'm a
[ __ ] this girl up Luna is [ __ ] up man
so with with this girl I remember I went
into the I went into the boys bathroom I
got this towel and then I soaked that
[ __ ] up like it was like a hundred
pounds and I looked at her and she was
like you're not gonna hit me I'm like
you literally just been beating the [ __ ]
out of me for the past hour I was like
if you whip me one more time I'm gonna
whip you back so she whips me and then
she looked at me and she tries to run
for it
I whip her so [ __ ] hard you just hear
her on her ass and she falls to the
floor and she starts crying and then at
that moment I didn't feel bad
I remember I felt Vindicated and she was
like that's what you get [ __ ] he writes
she like she she whipped me so hard I
had bruises all over my legs that's how
bad she was whipping me you know like
you're the like in you know like Korean
culture like the younger ones always get
bullied and punked all the time yeah and
I just had it I was like you know what
I'm done with this and I whipped her so
[ __ ] bad and this is like the type of
[ __ ] that would happen at the church
this girl oh just the preference this I
was also in elementary school yeah yeah
yeah
Hallelujah nights for kids yeah this is
like me I think it was like in fifth
grade yeah so
um in sixth grade
I don't know what the [ __ ] this girl was
doing she was screaming at everyone to
shut up because for a time like in it's
it's Washington right so like it rains a
lot and sometimes to prevent kids from
having like dirty muddy wet shoes
bringing back into school they would
just have indoor recess
you know and then so it's just gets
[ __ ] loud with kids in the classroom
free to do whatever they want for an
hour
and
when I got really loud this girl started
screaming like [ __ ] up everyone's shut
up and then she started flipping the
light switch up and down like clicking
up and down
and then for whatever reason I was just
so annoyed I had it I was just so
annoyed with her I put my hand on the
light I was like stop it right now
and then she said don't spit on me and
she's one of those and spit on me did
every kid [ __ ] do that or I know
everybody did that right it's like a
universal thing it would spit on you
yeah and then I did the same thing I
said I didn't spit on you and I you
should have done the Korean thing where
you have pop in your mouth
is rice starts flying at it
but as soon as I said that I turned
around and walked away
right and then I heard ah
how right in the back of my neck no
[ __ ] way and I had to feel it I had
to feel it and it was [ __ ] straight
up loogy
with the boogers and [ __ ] what and the
trailer trash is happening right now so
I had took that loogie hand and I
slapped her across the face that's some
[ __ ] franchise and then it was right
then and there I don't remember about
split up right there right and then we
were sent straight to the principal
and she and I had detention for a day
and it was just like yeah the principal
[ __ ] went in on me for hitting a girl
it's so interesting like
you know these like weird roles when we
were kids because I feel like when
you're a kid your strength is equal
girls get big
like these girls were [ __ ] huge like
okay I remember this one girl I'ma say
her name just because
every every kid in elementary school had
this girl in in school it was a girl
that was abnormally stronger than all
the boys yeah this girl was stick skinny
as [ __ ] and she used to play bloody
knuckles with guys and she would [ __ ]
everybody up there's like always those
girls yeah in like later stages of
Elementary and then into Middle School
where they just challenge boys because
they are bigger than them this girl
sticks skinny as hell she had knockers
in her hair all the time [ __ ] up teeth
this girl's name was Jules right so
Jewels would [ __ ]
everybody up and she always wanted to
play bloody knuckles always because her
[ __ ] was Jagged as hell so Jewels would
go around just beating the [ __ ] out of
everybody how unfair is it that I can't
defend myself from Miss Menace yeah and
she had the she had the craziest [ __ ]
up teeth but she would beat me up all
the time it wasn't just me it was every
dude yeah which is so weird yeah man
those there's like always those girls
though those girl bullies in in those
stages of adolescents like girls who
just [ __ ] dominate you and it's and
you're a boy and you feel like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] cause this girl is like [ __ ]
like dominating you a hundred we've all
had those dude like I remember like in
Hallelujah Night there was a this one
time a
uh you know I think as a boy you do a
lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] there's another
girl
and she asked me to go to the bathroom
with her and just wait outside because
she was scared because people were
telling scary stories and you know when
you're younger you have a crazy
imagination and me as a boy I was like
you shouldn't have asked me I'm
mischievous so she goes in the bathroom
and then she goes okay I'm gonna turn on
the faucet because I want you to hear me
pee so he turns on the sink and she goes
to the bathroom guess what I do oh
she's screaming at the top of her lungs
and I flip it back on I'm like what
happened she was
already okay she goes oh my God I was so
scared
I just left she hate dude this is a
crazy story about that girl too
and I might have been the onslaught to
her Insanity because so later on she
started dating this other guy at church
and dude every church has crazy stories
it's always like a crazy person so she
was madly in love with this other guy at
a different church right and while they
were going out
first of all I never liked this guy I
thought he was a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
either way
when they broke up she had such a bad
breakup with him and she was so madly in
love she didn't want to let him go so I
didn't know that when you broke up with
somebody you have a choice just to be
like no
no that was what I learned apparently
there's a choice I disagree they broke
up and she was just like no no we're not
broken up but in his mind they were
broken up yeah so I guess long story
short from what I remember from what I'm
recollecting you know they were broken
up for a couple of weeks but he was you
know on his way to flirting with other
girls or whatnot as she found out but
they're broken up yeah you can do
whatever he wants but not in her mind
they're still together so this fool
comes to our church uh because he was he
was bouncing back from our church to his
other church because obviously he was
dating this girl
this book comes up one day and he has
slashes all over what
so like
like his face has all these like deep
scratches I'm like
yo what the [ __ ] happened and so
somebody at the church told me that she
broke into his house late at night to
[ __ ] him up and she was trying to
scratch his face off oh my God and so he
had chunks of just like skin missing
from his face from her taking her nails
and digging it into his face what the
[ __ ] she broke into his mouth broke into
his house waited for him in the dark in
his room for him to come back so I don't
know how long she was there she could
have been there for like six hours I
would have serious PTSD dude
[ __ ] this guy up and nobody really
felt bad for him because he was kind of
an [ __ ] but at the same time like
that's pretty [ __ ] nuts yeah and in
that scenario are you not allowed to
like Spartan kick her in the stuff
dude dude that's just crazy Bend
yourself at that point yeah even I I
mean I told you that story about that
time my ex like [ __ ] punched me in
the face I didn't hit her back I knew it
would have been so bad like there's no
[ __ ] way I could the only reason I
guess if I would say this then you know
please don't clip this and turn me to a
bad person yeah like if my life was in
danger if it's like a girl swinging at
me because she's angry yeah I don't care
right if she's like
she's not an MMA fighter right it's not
like she's [ __ ] like Amanda Nunes
yeah you know trying to knock my head
off but she's swinging at me shoving me
or whatever
I'm not gonna hit her because my life's
not in danger yeah if she's trying to
come at me with intent to like seriously
hurt me then I might have to you know
you know shove her in front of a car
let's do something yeah right and I
think a lot of people have been a lot of
people are seeing that online right now
where I think a lot of guys are getting
a little Fed Up of like The Narrative of
a girl can just hit a guy whenever they
want yeah and I still don't believe a
guy should hit a girl right just because
there is a power and strength
discrepancy yeah but if a girl's coming
at you with a bat a weapon trying to
seriously kill you then you should
probably be able to defend yourself you
should be able to defend yourself and
then there's that there's just that
silver lining of like KO or I don't know
like choker out I mean we've definitely
seen it before
yeah and we've seen it online too where
you know a girl's like swing at a dude
and a guy just knocks her out I think a
lot of people online go you know stupid
stupid game win stupid prizes which I
100 agree but in all honesty
I mean you could have shoved her like
held her down or something I don't think
the full-on blown knockout was necessary
yeah right just because there is the
strength discrepancy I don't think I
would do that but like the girl who's
coming at me with a knife oh something's
gonna happen yeah you know I mean but
there's also like just the reason why a
lot of girls do that is just they really
believe oh they're not gonna do nothing
they're not gonna do nothing like you
don't know when anyone could snap I
wonder how a lot of girls feel about
that because when I see that on Twitter
um a lot of girls don't side with the
with the girl yeah right they don't ever
side with the girl which I thought it
was going to be the opposite but a lot
of women on Twitter when I read that
like why the [ __ ] would you swing at a
full-grown man expecting him not to do
something but the exact same time it's
really hard to say well what did she do
yeah what did she say right that's like
yeah but then that's like that's because
everyone's trying to get context yeah
yeah once everybody gets context you
know like even the [ __ ] this is such
old [ __ ] like the Ray Rice thing
everyone saw the [ __ ] video I was
like dude you could have just stuck like
stiff armed her at them like no matter
what was going on like you're a [ __ ]
professional NFL running back dude the
internet has made a lot of things change
yeah um specifically when it comes to
opinions about this type of stuff
because I remember where you look we
were just talking about growing up it
was like no matter what under any
circumstance do you ever you never lay
your hand on a woman which is what we
grew up with and is what I still agree
with right but now you're seeing kids
being like well if you put your hands on
me I'm just gonna knock you out and
that's just wild that's yeah that's just
[ __ ] wild yeah like that's becoming
the accepted Norm yeah I think they're
getting it from like
these [ __ ] backdoor internet Corners
you know they're like they're watching
that kind of [ __ ] they're into that [ __ ]
or something I don't know or they're
they're being influenced by it because
it's like a different way of thought
because our society has overcome the
days of Sean Connery just slapping women
if they talk back you know that
interview yeah did you see the interview
between uh Pierce Morgan and um Andrew
Tate no no Pierce Morgan I don't [ __ ]
like Pierce Morgan yeah no I'd like I
try not to click on Andrew Tate stuff
because all your stuff all your stuff
the whole algorithm just wants you to
watch more so essentially with that
whole Pierce Morgan Andrew Tate thing
what happened was you know Pierce boring
is trying to do his little gotcha
journalism thing yeah you know he has a
habit of constantly interrupting people
as they talk trying to get his point
across and he just did a terrible job
right and basically agitate dismantle
this [ __ ] yeah right which the
interesting thing is it's like this is
what the internet does like they'll see
the biggest argument for Andrew Tate is
that they'll find a clip where Andrew
Tate says something that they agree with
that's you know fairly intelligent yeah
and they sum up his whole personality
with those few clips and so agitate
throughout this whole interview Pierce
Morgan is bringing bringing up things
where he says this is what you said and
he goes no this is what I meant the
problem with that is that
you're allowing Andrew Tate to create
his own narrative he could create The
Narrative of you didn't listen to the
clip right this is what I was actually
saying but that's all that's all
conjecture that happened afterwards
after he's already laid his influence
and after people already interpreted the
way that he said he didn't mean to say
it yeah so it's it's basically him
backpedaling throughout the whole thing
but Pierce Morgan didn't say that you
know he was not prepared so Andrew Tate
can control the narrative and say like
well this is what I actually mean by it
so what I said that women are all [ __ ]
and dirt bags and they don't deserve uh
you know I'm by the way this is not what
he actually said I'm just saying I'm
just kind of giving you paraphrasing
paraphrasing right it's like women have
no value if they sleep if they sleep
with men because and then he'll say it
as like no what I actually said was that
if a woman wants to treat her body that
way that's her choice and I completely
agree with like I have a way to treat my
body but if you want to do it that way
then there are consequences for that
that's not what you said though yeah
that's not what you said you said women
have zero value if they sleep with men
and they're [ __ ] yeah but they then he
could change the narrative and so people
will take Clips out of that Pierce
Morgan review because Pierce Morgan did
such a bad job and they go you know what
see Andrew T's not a bad guy this it's
the problem with giving people a
platform yeah right right and uh
speaking of people on a platform
uh yeah why don't you explain because I
didn't dig too much into it so Kanye
West
is under a lot of scrutiny right and I
think what I want to talk about on this
podcast for a lot of people especially
if they're younger viewers and who
didn't grow up on his music or were they
weren't there for the for the onset of
Kanye's career right so Kanye to me
became really popular probably when I
was like in junior high or a freshman in
high school yeah right or that's when I
heard of him he was already building a
name for himself he was a rapper
producer he wanted to be a producer he
was already producing beats for Jay-Z
and Rockefeller or whatever whatnot but
he wanted to be a rapper and then if you
watched in his interview on Netflix you
see a lot of these well-known rappers
like Pharrell Jay-Z a bunch of people
talking about he is the next one this
guy is literally a genius yeah which in
his own right when you look at his
career in terms of what he's done with
music fashion and everything else I'm
going to give him credit where credits
do yeah he has a huge influence their
influencers influencer exactly there is
not a single person out there even now
there's a lot of people backpedaling
they go I never liked the way Yeezys
look that's funny because you have six
pairs of them yeah you know you had to
get it for your Cloud you cannot like
him for what he's doing now but you
can't erase what he's done in the past
right by the way this is not me
defending I'm just giving him I'm just
giving everybody context to who Kanye
West was before the person that you see
now yeah we'll get to that part yeah
because a lot of people are kind of only
seeing his last two years yeah and
they're not really understanding where
he is right so why people loved him so
much I have a very huge soft spot for
Kanye like when you talk about his
earlier albums that went mainstream I
can recite almost every single [ __ ]
lyric yeah that's how influential he was
so Kanye if you guys want to know
he was kind of the guy that put rap in a
different genre right because at the
time when he was rapping about his [ __ ]
rap was about what I mean no it wasn't
everybody right because we did have
those like those radio hits but if you
were a rapper you were a gangster yeah a
lot of it in the 90s yeah and early
2000s was gangster rap yeah and Kanye
West and among other rappers as well
they were doing this as well too but
Kanye really did it really well where he
made it the prep you look very popular
where he even started changing fashion
before he had his fashion line where he
had the double collared uh the shirts
remember when people were doing that
yeah yeah when they had the uh the Ralph
Lauren polos Ralph Lauren originally was
what for what people who golf yeah Rich
white people you know Yuppie ass college
kids sweater vests the sweater vest yeah
what did Kanye do Kanye brought that
[ __ ] into hip-hop saying like this is
what we're gonna wear yeah along with
Pharrell and everybody else so when you
see how much influence he had even
before he had the Yeezy line and
everything else he's done with his own
clothing line what he's done with gap uh
Valencia whoever the [ __ ] that it is
right Nike Adidas he was already doing
that then he was somebody who had a lot
of foresight yeah he was the one that uh
basically went away with all the extra
large baggy [ __ ] yeah yeah those
t-shirts used to be down to the knees
yeah
I remember in high school yeah I
remember in high school there was one
dude that was literally copying Kanye's
and you could see him always with polo
shirts so this is how big an influence
he had right and he was rapping about a
lot of things that other rappers weren't
rapping about right yeah Jesus Walks
right about Christianity that's what the
that's the first time I actually heard
of him because I wasn't obviously up
into like a lot of underground like
hip-hop stuff and that was the first
time I had heard of him but I was
listening to the song on the radio like
what the [ __ ] yeah because we were deep
to the church then we were like what
yeah yeah and he did a Christian song
that was mainstream hip-hop and it was a
[ __ ] hit every album that he put out
was different from his last right
whether people liked it at first didn't
like it he always reinvented himself
constantly that's why you never see this
guy disappear off of Pop Culture he
never got stuck doing the same thing
over and over once like he continually
reinvented himself over and over again
yeah every album was a hit every album
smash whatever he touched was gold he
had the Midas touch so next thing up you
see the beginning of his Insanity yeah
and uh
who's ever thought that Kanye was going
to be somebody different than who he is
now did you all forget what happened
during Hurricane Katrina
oh [ __ ] yeah Mike Myers they're talking
about millions of people dying from This
Disaster Holmes drowning people losing
everything that they love and own it was
like a celebrity fundraiser it was like
the PBS Telethon yeah yeah Telethon
is right there this [ __ ] is still funny
to this day I can't believe how long ago
it was because you watch it and it's in
standard death you know it was so long
yeah that was 2005. yeah yeah out of
nowhere zero context pause Bush hates
black people you cut Chris Rock yeah
uh not remember it was uh Chris Tucker
oh it was it Chris Tucker because he has
those eyes that were he's like a deer in
headlights
dude that [ __ ] was like what the [ __ ]
and this is really where you got to see
who Kanye is yeah Kanye never gave a
[ __ ] about what anybody did he was
literally in his own lane yeah he was
almost prophetic in how where he was
going to be everything he said that he
was gonna do he did right yeah
um this to me and I was really thinking
about this I was thinking really deep
was where where did the the true demise
of like Kanye start and this is my
theory and I was kind of blown away when
I thought about this
was Kanye actually is a classic comic
book superhero villain
so the onset of his Insanity you know
where it really really began prior to
this uh I think his mom the death of his
mom yeah yeah like every [ __ ] comic
book superhero or villain yeah there is
that one tragic moment that they have
where that turns them evil or it turns
them good yeah the death of his mom
turned him this way right right so after
his mom died right so if you guys don't
know how his mama his mom is named Tonda
which named after his album also named
after his university and everything else
um his his Sports Entertainment Company
his mother dies from a botched plastic
surgery operation yeah
um and after his mom died he has said
repeatedly over and over that he is to
blame for his mom's death
multiple times
if I had never chased my dreams in LA
and I stayed in Chicago where I went to
New York my mother would have never died
because the culture of La is kind of
what [ __ ] with his mom's head is what
he feels right so she feels that she
wasn't beautiful enough and this isn't
stuff that every vapid human being or
you know just people in La will always
feel like this because that's the level
of comparison that you're dealing with
consistently in L.A and his mom in his
mind fell victim to that yeah you know
there was uh I forget where it was but
he was in the middle of an interview if
it was a TMZ or something and
he was like ranting about that like
Hollywood like La culture he was like I
got liposuction and it was just like a
two and on one like interview but then
you can see the bullpen of all the staff
working and he got up off the chair
turned around look everybody everybody
in here it was TMZ yeah he was like I I
got liposuction for you that's like how
he sees it and you could see that he has
this resentment for that culture I guess
yeah and listen to a certain degree I
100 agree with him there this city does
crazy things to people you are
constantly when you're in especially
when you're in the Limelight you are
constantly under everybody's scrutiny
now a lot of people can say like this is
what you signed up for not really yeah
like certain people did like they want
attention so bad they'll do absolutely
anything to get it and this is what they
signed up for some people are just
artists and they want to create and
that's the thing that made them great it
made them uh that put in the spotlight
right but in entertainment you don't get
to choose what you get to have so
after his mother died in all these
concerts he was crying profusely about
his mom he every time he tried to do the
song Hey Mama he would always ball yeah
and even till this day he still blames
himself uh for his mother's death and he
still talks about in interviews every
time he did a concert he would cry every
time that song comes on because he
really does blame himself this is the
classic comic book super villain yeah
and so what you're seeing now
from what I what I'm theorizing is that
he is trying to in the most toxic most
painful way like every super villain who
has actually good intentions because of
something bad that happened in their
life he is trying to change the world
that he sees right now as absolutely
deplorable into something that his a
world that his that would have kept his
mother alive
this is his this is his motive like a
bit of righteousness yes this is
literally rooted in his righteousness to
create a world that what that could have
been done and it would have kept his mom
alive
if his mom didn't have to feel like she
wasn't beautiful enough if he didn't
take to take her to La this idea of like
commercialism and everything else
everything he's doing right now is is
for his mom for his for his deceased mom
and the mistakes that he made that he
could have fixed that could have kept
her life is how he feels I'm assuming
that
um it probably would have been his mom's
wish for him to be such a strong man of
God right I mean 100 yeah it sounds like
it because everything I mean look we're
kind of seeing manic episodes pretty
much I mean he's clinically bipolar yeah
yeah and and like which comes with uh
what is it delusions of grandeur
which is why he sees himself as if not
God a damn a god
something way more special yeah and the
rest of us ants yeah you know that's
like literally the how he talks of
himself and then you know just to go
further into the timeline then then now
we go into the current timeline that
people really start to remember him for
especially like gen Z kids who didn't
really grow up on him they see Kanye
West as the Trump father the Maga yeah
right because he was doing the whole uh
was this uh Mega hat damn I already
forgot it
but like the one thing that yeah even
though I just said it it was it was a
make uh make America great again so he
was putting on this whole thing and you
know everybody had this Theory to why he
was doing this because he wants to get
close to Trump so because if he gets
close to Trump
um he could enact really good changes
within his community so
which I think was a really good theory
right and you could see it in the way
that he was doing things
um then he's obviously he puts himself
back into the heat again because he
starts saying things recently that uh
talking about uh George Floyd's death
and he basically said George Floyd
didn't died from Suffocation he died
because he was high off of fentanyl
stemming from uh the Candace Owens
documentary and then obviously he goes
with Candace Owen and they they wear the
the antithesis of black lives matter
which is White lives matter yeah which
White lives matter if you guys don't
know was is rooted in shutting down what
black lives matter was there's a whole
thing about black lives matter which I
don't really agree I didn't know that
black lives matter too was an actual
organization yeah I thought it was just
a movement there's like they have real
leaders and [ __ ] and yeah yeah and
there's a lot of controversy I mean
that's what it was though BLM movement
from what I thought was just a
Grassroots people on the street through
the internet that's what they called it
it's just what the people said you know
but I guess it turns out either
yeah it it was either birth out of a
genius or it somebody totally took
advantage of a trademark yeah and so you
know if you watch the kennesawan
documentary which I did this is one
thing that I have to do my own research
on but if this stuff is true that that
there's two separate things right
there's the black letters matter
movement and then there's this
organization I had no idea about the
organization like I knew there was like
non like profit charity stuff I didn't
realize that they were taking millions
and millions and millions of dollars
yeah because if that was the case I too
as somebody if I donated money I want to
see where it's going yeah I want to know
and I think that's what the documentary
said the saddest part is like it's worse
than the [ __ ] Coney 2020 2012. I
forgot about invisible children yeah
that's crazy how [ __ ] it's the most
viral thing ever in the history of the
world and it was the most forgotten
thing in like well back down to people
what Coney is because people probably
don't remember Joseph Coney is a war
Lord in Uganda I believe and he takes on
tens of thousands of child soldiers and
basically child brides and all this [ __ ]
and he is committing atrocities all
across
and um
pretty much uh this organization called
The Invisible children which I had heard
of years prior
um because they're a Christian
organization
they
um were documentary filmmakers and they
went out there to film what the hell was
happening there which is just some
atrocious [ __ ] and the thing was all the
their previous documentaries they would
do the church tours and churches like a
Christians would hear and see about it
but then they wouldn't really
go anywhere from there they're trying to
bring awareness to what the hell is
happening to this from this evil you
know crazy man and so what they decided
to do was make the most viral video ever
and they did a good [ __ ] job
to capture your attention to give you
all the information and then like have a
plan of action
actually right it was like donate 15
bucks or whatever something we'll give
you a care package of all this you know
vandalism [ __ ] in a box so you can post
Coney 2012 bumper stickers everywhere
you know and make stencil you know kits
and [ __ ] well it worked like holy it had
like 70 million millions of millions of
views yeah first day
and like it got to everyone saying Mr
President have you heard seen this video
Oprah have you seen this video trying to
get the most influential powerful people
to do something about this
and like dude that means the video
worked
well a lot of people started getting
suspicious about their
funding and themselves as an as an
organization
you know and to be honest like it's
really weird the scrutiny they got
because they were truly transparent they
showed everyone's salary what they did
with the money and all this [ __ ] and the
leader the guy who founded everything he
made 70 000 a year in a salary yeah
that's not
bad that's not greedy yeah you know
that's his life he has a wife and kid
you know whatever and he does a lot of
[ __ ] work
well you know our friend Jason yeah he
uh Mutual missionary friend of ours like
he's been all over the world like doing
[ __ ] like that too he was at a
conference in San Diego and that guy was
that was there oh [ __ ] to give a keynote
speech and he's like tomorrow we're
gonna post the video and we just hope
that it does its work like because he
just basically explained Joseph only to
them as well and their movement what
they're trying to do and he was like
yeah so we're posting it tomorrow you
know pray for us hope it goes viral
and it was Colony 2012. wow yeah well
the scrutiny got to him
the leader founder of the invisible
children and he was found naked on the
street masturbating
he just snapped lost his [ __ ] with his
[ __ ]
like completely was just not a normal
person
yeah and so it like shut everything down
in a matter of two weeks
I'm [ __ ] crazy well like that's the
saddest part like everybody knew what
who Joseph Coney was now right and now
more than anything people didn't give a
[ __ ] because this guy jacking off yeah
now they know but they also don't give a
[ __ ] because your founder was caught
jacking off and your funding is Shady or
whatever which is like I I don't know
but anyhoo so compared to that it sounds
like the BLM movement is even more
nefarious yeah yeah I mean the worst
part was while this was happening during
Ed and I lived together movement BLM
organization organization yes yeah the
organization yeah the worst part about
this story is that when Ed and I were
living together uh there was a
restaurant that opened across it's
called King of New York Pizza
[Laughter]
I was like that is the worst timing I've
ever seen in my whole life dude but they
did pretty well yeah it was pretty
[ __ ] good yeah they're not at that
location but I think they're still open
okay and somewhere else in K-Town that
[ __ ] made me die dude there was a couple
things that pandemic so right before
pandemic happened right across from my
place that I was living at the time a
Chinese travel agency opened nice but
worse they closed down so fast come to
boost
it was it closed down so fast I was like
damn that is some terrible [ __ ]
timing dude there was like so many of
these like different scams that are
happening right and you know just to
wrap back to like the the Kanye thing
um there's just a lot of controversy
behind and we're going to get to the
Crux of it right which this is the
controversy that happened recently was
he said anti-semitic uh comments on
Twitter right prior to this he said some
other crazy [ __ ] Elon Musk got it back
on Twitter
um but now he's banned again and a lot
of Jewish people are speaking out
against this which they should right
and this kind of wraps back to you know
how funny is it that he was actually the
one you know
he got a lot of scrutiny for being
around Trump
lovely genius farts this podcast is
brought to you by betterhelp online
therapy my friends and let me tell you
something I love it I've been talking
about mental health for quite a while
and you know how much it's helped me in
my every day life I've been working on
my physical health but I don't work on
my physical health until I work on my
mental health because if I'm not
mentally prepared to go through all that
[ __ ] guess what
that's where better help comes and if
you think talking about your problems if
you think I don't know going to therapy
makes you weak you are wrong my friends
going to therapy makes you strong and it
makes you a better person because there
are certain things that you don't want
to talk about even to your own family
members maybe even to your closest
friends and you want to be in a safe
space without judgment well guess what I
do that with my therapist with better
help super easy to access and guess what
these therapists are trained to help you
and figure out these challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills which some of us didn't really
grow up with and did you even know about
this fact about them right it is
literally literally super super
convenient just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with the
therapist and if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime and it couldn't be any more
simpler plus it's more convenient more
accessible and more affordable than
in-person therapy get unstuck with
better help learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's better help help.com
hello fresh hello fresh that's who's
sponsoring this podcast you guys know
how much I love my hello fresh if you
don't know what hello fresh is let me
tell you something about them let me
tell you something skip trips to the
grocery store and count on hellofresh to
make home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why hellofresh is
America's number one meal kit subscribe
to hellofresh and check save money off
your fall to-do list hellofresh is 25
cheaper than take out and less expensive
than grocery shopping too have your
pumpkin spice and eat it too with a
rotating selection of fall inspired
items from hellofresh Market from brunch
kits to a fall dessert board you'll find
everything you need for all your
favorite Autumn occasions like
tailgating Oktoberfest and more my
friends hellofresh is now offering vegan
recipes on the menu every week made
without animal products or any kind of
like Dairy meat eggs or honey so
everybody has something they can enjoy
from hellofresh and the food that you
can make from them is [ __ ] amazing I
love it I gotta tell you something man
the food that I've made freaking wild
delicious I had like this uh chicken
pasta thing I made with like sun-dried
tomatoes oh that [ __ ] was fired made it
for the wifey and she'd even know it was
something that was from hellofresh had
absolutely no idea she was shocked she
loved it and that's why we're still
married and we're still in love so go to
hellofresh.com
brain65 and use code brain65 for 65 off
plus free shipping once again go to
hellofresh.com
brain65 and use codebrain65 for 65 off
plus free shipping hellofresh America's
number one meal kid
foreign
genius farts this holiday season I'll be
giving thanks to our friends over at
manscape everyone loves turkey and
stuffing but you'll be looking like
dessert with the help of manscapes
performance package 4.0 if your balls
are looking a little scary down there
why haven't you hopped on this deal my
friends and that's where your buddy
David saw over here at genius brain is
here to help trim your pumpkins by going
to manscape.com and use code genius for
free shipping and 20 off this amazing
amazing deal inside you'll find that a
lot more 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold all your goodies it's a
cornucopia for your balls my friends
listen if you nicked your balls you know
how much that hurts it just it just
won't stop bleeding over and over all
over the place well guess what I don't
have to deal with that stupid [ __ ]
anymore because I have my manscape 4.0
package to save my ball sack and also my
marriage oh God get 20 off and free
shipping with the code genius
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
genius be thankful this holiday season
for the best gift of all from Match Game
your balls will thank you
and now he's doing things very
trump-esque and what I mean by that is
that if we go ahead and break down what
he said right number one I didn't know
what death con was first of all I found
out it's not even death con it's Defcon
with an F right yeah so it's Defcon I
didn't know that because you said
deathcon defense
yeah so it's like it's like a defense
protocol in the military when [ __ ]
really gets he said death he said death
con yeah which I truly believe he
thought it was actually Defcon yeah but
like
you know if you were just getting a
trigger reaction that sounds very
nefarious yeah he goes I'm going Defcon
3 on Jewish people in caps yeah right
which by absolutely no means and in no
way despite what he wanted to say by it
there is
when you say things like that and you
embolden you Empower people to do evil
things who have already had evil
thoughts this is where the issue happens
right same thing with
Donald Trump when he was saying
very anti-asian things and you know
people's you know reasoning was like
well it did come from China I was like
we understand yeah but him as somebody
who was a leader in front of the world
but you are you have the power to
embolden either really good people or
really bad people yeah and the way that
he went about it decided to put people
who look like us in Jeopardy yeah this
is the same thing that Kanye is doing
yeah right so
there I was trying to read through
different
you know comments where they were
defending Kanye saying like well Defcon
is actually this this is not what people
are talking about we're talking about
how
half Hazard he's been with his words and
the effect that he has because how
influential he is and so
this is why he's in hot water right now
so because of this
everybody's backing out yeah oh my gosh
Adidas dropping like flies Adidas
dropped him yeah dropped them Balenciaga
cut ties with him his bank his bank
Chase yeah JP Morgan Chase cut ties with
him uh the list goes on and on and on
you guys can find that I think there was
a vulture article talking about every
person that kind of decided to just cut
ties with him yeah the funniest thing
happened though it actually happened
literally a couple hours ago where there
was an article about this and legit I
don't know it's because I was just it
caught me at a good time but I started
crying laughing so this will walked in
to Skechers
unannounced and ask for a deal
and Kanye West one of the most
influential fashion designers got denied
by Skechers God [ __ ] escorted out it
got escorted out first of all you get
denied by Skechers yeah Rock Bottom dude
oh my God
oh my God he's about to go to K-Swiss
yeah his last drop is LA Gear
the Fila he's gonna go to Fila whatever
he could he's going to go
hey Toms you got denied by [ __ ]
Skechers the shoes that nobody wants to
wear and they said you're out
he so apparently his uh his his net
worth was 1.9 billion dollars it's now
down to 400 million so he lost 1.5
billion of his net worth because it was
tied to Adidas
here's one thing that people don't
understand right they go we're going to
cancel Adidas we're going to just we're
going to cancel Kanye we're gonna
destroy him you can't destroy him
you literally cannot destroy he is the
influencers influencer yeah
despite all this stuff going away you
think he's broke
now he still has a lot of capital he has
a lot of capital and he still has a lot
of influence as much as people hate him
there's just as many that still support
him and [ __ ] love him yeah you know
like I'm not a big fan of him like I'm
not a big follower of him
I am so curious to see how he's gonna
pull himself out of this I think we are
I want to see what happens next you know
you know this is I'm telling you this is
the best comic book story ever of this
comic book film yeah right so Superman
just whooped his ass a little bit which
is everybody going against him but just
like every [ __ ] villain in every
[ __ ] comic book story what happens
they come right back yeah and this is
really his story right now so at the at
the end of the day like you know Kanye
is knocking on everybody's door to get
you know what whatever his next line of
clothing is because he still owns the
rights to Yeezy whatever design he made
with Adidas they own so they could
replicate it duplicate it however much
they want right but then but the name
Yeezy he owns they won't be able to call
it easy so bro like open up a factory in
Vietnam or something she will yeah he
will he'll like people are like well how
is he gonna get things made you think
China gives a [ __ ] yeah about how he's
gonna get [ __ ] they care you think
there's Chinese Jews
you think they're gonna be like it's
apple juice they have orange juice
we have so many juice it's like you
think literally it's gonna be a Chinese
person like I don't care what you say
how much money you have yeah and that's
really what's gonna happen oh yeah he's
gonna probably go on his own and be
independent because once again once
again sway did have the answers
right and he said he goes you know what
sway did have the answer yeah he's gonna
go and make his production in his own
right and he's gonna figure it out and
people are still going to buy his stuff
yeah you know why because hype culture
is really big specifically in hip-hop
because let me tell you this even if you
don't support Kanye there's some [ __ ]
head little hypebeast that's gonna be
like you know what nobody's supporting
Kanye's stuff and there's only a few
pieces I'm gonna make sure I'm gonna
grab it because I know what happens
later on it's going to grow in value
because it was a limited Kanye piece
right because he has such a huge and
Powerful moment
so Yeezys now have gone up in value on
the street I guarantee it because now
they can't even recreate those shoes
yeah so the whatever Yeezys that you had
whether it was the the breads the
taillights the turtle doves whatever the
[ __ ] that it is they're never coming
back again they're like Kobe's Kobe
shoes will never come back because
whatever you know when he before he
passed away right so
this is what it is he under Kanye one
thing he does understand is the power of
capitalism
everybody is full of [ __ ] all of you
[ __ ] out there and you know it
you know for a fact you're out here
tweeting oh [ __ ] Kanye I'm not gonna buy
it any of his stuff you're gonna do it
on the DL because you're gonna try to
resell it and make money off of it
because you love capitalism and I'm not
defending Kanye at all but this is a
this is a part of the stuff that he's
kind of proving himself right right now
in terms of this aspect I don't agree
with all the other [ __ ] yeah but the
world that he is trying to create he's
like Thanos right now he's doing it in
the most destructive [ __ ] way
possible yeah right yeah he's collecting
all his Stones basically yeah so now you
have this weird space where people are
trying to really understand like do we
hate this guy
or is he or does he have a bigger plan
and this is what's confusing a lot of
people well I just listened to his
interview with Lex Friedman oh how was
that people are telling me I should
listen to it yeah yeah it was good
um I mean he goes off in his tangents
and he changes the subject sometimes it
feels like it's edited in some random
comedic way but it's just the way he
talks yeah a long [ __ ] five minute
pause yeah but
um man Lex
he's if you don't know who Lex Friedman
and he is he's like a engineer at MIT he
builds robots and [ __ ] he's also a robot
himself yeah yeah he's kind of like a
robot himself but he's a black belt in
Jiu Jitsu here are you really good too
excellent at the guitar to
um he's a really cool guy always wears a
suit
super smart very calculated ask really
great questions
very emotionless
but
um he pushed back at Kanye because Lex
Friedman being a Russian Ukrainian Jew
yeah and um he was trying to bring the
light the problem with what Connie was
saying and he held his ground yeah which
is pretty amazing to see right and um he
pushed back on the I on the what exact
like is this just didn't seem like Kanye
understood
what anti-Semitism is yeah yeah because
the Kanye West it's look yeah all these
people that screwed him over in the
record label you know industry in
Hollywood in uh fashion and like
wherever he's been in in his legal
counsel and his accounting or whatever
um they've been Jewish people right
but because so many of them screwed him
over he's saying the Jews he's
generalized them and did a collective on
them and what Lex Friedman was
arguing with him was like these
individuals did it was like stop saying
the Jews did this to you you know say
the names yeah he said call them out
you're a powerful person you're an
influential person say them by their
name and call them out it's just saying
the Jews yeah and I think that was
really important because even you know
me too like I didn't grow up around
Jewish people yeah I don't know many
Jewish people at all I didn't meet a
Jewish person until I like came to L.A
same here I already knew one Jewish
person whose last name was Rubenstein
Rubenstein but he wasn't even actually
like ethnically Jew right he was uh he's
a religiously Jew or something like but
his last name changed he changed the
Rubenstein or something like that right
but I don't I didn't know anybody who
was ethnically [ __ ] that had like ties
to the Holocaust right and until I came
here and I met two Jewish people yeah so
I need to like the Jewish people I've
met have been at the workplace whatever
because in our neighborhoods in our area
I just don't meet them otherwise to us
as as third party objective viewers they
just look like white people to us you
know why people with some of the [ __ ]
craziest humor I've ever heard in my
life Jewish people be [ __ ] funny dude
yeah they can make jokes out of anything
it's it's the people who know pain
they're the funniest people for sure
Black Folk and Jewish people man maybe
funniest [ __ ] that's why they're so
funny yeah I think that's why like like
Koreans can be funny too across Asia
because we
our grandparents have seen something
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
that that passes on generationally too
like but yeah like
um and by the way the Holocaust wasn't
that long ago yeah people talk about it
like it was 200 years ago yeah it wasn't
that long ago there's Holocaust
Survivors I met a couple like 39 to 45
yeah we yeah yeah dude so
um
uh I I was on uh set and there was a a
lady who uh who her parents were there
too right and it's it's a funny story
because of how it ended but not the
story that they were telling but they I
you know I asked a few questions
and they're like New York Jewish people
but you know it somehow got into a
conversation where she was talking about
um her family and she was talking about
her her uncle or something it was a
relative of her she remembered how
during the time during the Holocaust
they were her uncle was like a kitchen
worker yeah and he would like pass her
food by like stealing potatoes while he
was in the kitchen because he would he
he stitched a pocket inside of his pants
that would hold a potato so he could
give it to like
uh his like nieces and nephews or
whatever what which was her and stuff
like that and this is like some [ __ ] she
experienced Like This Woman's sitting in
front of me as we're having this
conversation and that person screwed
over Kanye West yeah
that's the Ridiculousness of like you
know generalizing people that way it's
such a crazy like hearing that story
blew my [ __ ] mind it was so funny
because her daughter came in and she
goes Ma
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I was like
he was like we're about to be upset
thanks for bringing the mood down with
your Holocaust stories oh my God
that type of humor even you know
conversation like that was so [ __ ]
funny to me yeah you know
nope so like
for I think a lot of Asian Americans and
a lot of us grow up around Jewish people
but for those of us who grew up in
church we know a hell of a lot about
them yeah Testament yeah for sure yeah
that's the only like idea that we know
about like Jewish people aside from that
we don't really know modern day Jewish
people so I'm not sure if you uh I don't
know why I don't know about this but
um I don't know why this shit's been
popping up in my feed but there is
this whole battle
in Jerusalem right yeah yeah it's like
in Israel Israel yeah and all these
videos are popping up on my [ __ ] were
like straight War yeah like people are
screaming at each other saying like you
know I think um
they're basically saying like what is
like it's their land and then the time
has come where they're gonna where God's
gonna kill them all yeah yeah what is
that [ __ ] yeah dude it's
[ __ ] up
and
this is It's a complicated situation for
sure
basically like look over thousands of
years Jerusalem has been sacked over and
over and over again since the days of
Jesus just fighting for Holy Land yeah
it's holy land and basically the people
who won at the end were the Muslims you
know through all the Crusades and all
the wars and all that you know it's the
Muslims and so on top of what used to be
I guess the Temple of Solomon is a
mosque now you know oh yeah so a lot of
people are salty about that and it's
like it's been there for like a thousand
years yeah yeah yeah yeah it happened a
long time ago you lost this war a long
time ago yeah and they did lose their
land so the Jewish people just became
this diaspora they went all over you
know like the the world especially
Europe yeah but over the years they've
just been persecuted everywhere they
went you know and they just kept moving
and moving until I think they went like
across from like North Africa all the
way back up the Mediterranean they're
just circling the Mediterranean and a
lot of them though ended up like in
Poland in like Eastern Europe you know
and over the hundreds of years their
complexions changed yeah yeah you know
but they still for those hundreds of
years
imagine that you know still hold on to
their Jewish ancestry you know like yeah
yeah I can't even imagine hundreds and
hundreds of years and and that connects
obviously into like the ethnic cleansing
of Hitler yes yes so people's so that's
the problem with Kanye what Kanye West
is saying when you say things like the
Jews run Hollywood the Jews run the
banks whatever like like a good number
of them do but that's because of the
history of their come up in America yeah
yeah you know what do they say today dry
cleaners are run by who
Koreans Koreans yeah your liquor store
your gas stations your black beer supply
stores yeah like
it just so happens that the movies
became a huge [ __ ] thing and you know
what banks are very lucrative yeah yeah
yeah you know it's just they've it's
been a family business thing you know
try getting into a car dealership
business good luck yeah yeah because
it's like my daddy's Daddy's daddy you
sell cars you know well that's the thing
too it's like I I mean I could sit here
and say I don't understand why Kanye
doesn't understand it but he is
clinically bipolar we've seen his manic
episodes literally recorded so I don't
expect
anything from him to be honest with you
if I'm going to be straight up I I don't
expect a moment of
Clarity or sanity to exist and when it
does exist I'm actually thoroughly
surprised like look if if the Tweet had
said like I'm sleepy I need to go death
Con 3 on some Koreans be like I honestly
just feel like
what did what do we do
but then also putting together like yeah
this guy's this guy's got issues yeah
what's the deal right and the idea for
him he's like trying to pass is so
expensive [ __ ] Koreans
you know but that's the problem though
that's the problem so when you start
saying stuff like that as an influential
person then right
you know what a lot people are just
going to start following that [ __ ] you
know like look when Trump came into the
presidency I started running my gas
station
yes yes the [ __ ] racist incident went
up 100 entire time he was in office so
yeah I had issues I had to deal with
because I I lived at the time in
Pasadena for how many years I never had
anybody say anything remotely racially
charged at me and during pandemic
happened multiple times and I was like
what the [ __ ] this has never happened
before so you know for people to say
like
and by the way too this is a very like
diverse in terms of how many cultures
are here in La you would think it
wouldn't happen here right yeah but it
was happening in Los Angeles which is
very [ __ ] odd like it's like been
here for what 10 years it's never
happened and then suddenly because they
felt empowered because the president of
the United States was backing them up
whether he was or what wasn't basically
the rhetoric that he had allowed for
this to happen and he wasn't taking
responsibility for it and that's
essentially what Kanye is doing he's not
taking responsibility for the stuff
that's happening because of the things
that he's saying like look at those
those [ __ ] Tiki Torch Charleston boys
yeah empowered by Trump you're gonna see
a bunch of hypebeast [ __ ] boys becoming
anti-semites because of Kanye dude there
was in on the LA freeway there was
people dude [ __ ] crazy they were they
were hanging up signs saying Kanye is
right with the [ __ ] hand in there and
all that [ __ ] which is [ __ ] crazy
because in my mind I'm like you know
he's black right yeah he's like you know
what yeah I got a little tear system
yeah
but let me tell him once we get rid of
those Jews
yeah I mean like this is this is the
thing too it's just feed stupidity
exactly and you know it's not even just
Kanye there's a lot of dumb kids who
want to do exactly what he's doing and
they don't want to accept personal
responsibility for everything and
because he is somebody who is an
influencer right who's highly
influential they'll use him as an
example they go well this guy he amassed
millions and billions of dollars who are
you to tell me that I can't be like him
when he's very successful clearly he's
doing something right yeah and people
use these straw man [ __ ] arguments
all the time yeah and this is how dumb
the youth is like the youth is becoming
this not all youth right because there
are very smart people there but because
of social media because these people are
allowed to infiltrate these kids lives
in a very personal way that has never
happened in the history of humanity yeah
because before
Liberties were very distant you only
heard things about them from what
interviews
right E.T
yeah we had entertainment whatever yeah
Entertainment Tonight
what else Hollywood Access Hollywood MTV
Awards whatever
and the occasional Paparazzi who had to
go hunt for their lives well guess what
now in order for you to be a celebrity
that has clout you have to share
everything about your life the access
that people have as celebrities means
that their impact is that much greater
yeah and people just don't understand
Kanye doesn't understand that still yeah
he's like I'm just a person no you stop
being just a person once you once you
became you that's that's the weird thing
with how well he Hypes himself up to be
a genius and the greatest of all time
while taking no responsibility for
anything he does and says I don't know
how that works yeah I I just look at him
as that kind of egomaniac that just
refuses to take an L yeah like your
friend the or the girl who just refuses
to not get dumped yeah whatever she's
like oh we're not dumped at all and
that's some crazy [ __ ] I wanted to go
back to the the I guess the issue with
having when you say these
um this kind of red of anti-Semitism you
know
um it's not like saying oh all Koreans
run liquor stores and gas stations
because statistically not all of them
yeah right yeah yeah yeah yeah but at
the same time like
it's I guess he Lex Friedman called it a
dog whistle like when you we hear that
like it that like the hairs under on on
Jewish people's next stand up because
that's the kind of rhetoric that was
used by Nazi Germany to kill them to
yeah to kill them to put all the blame
on society's problems onto the Jews you
know which started the society's support
Nazi Germany's people it's civilian
support for what they were doing to them
yeah you know and so if the writing's on
the wall like after George Floyd
happened and then all of a sudden the
Asian starts happening and then you
start seeing that the Jewish people are
next
like yeah you want to nip that [ __ ] on
the bud yeah even like we're we're not
Jewish at all you know but yeah I don't
wish this on another person's race I
don't wish this to happen to white
people either yeah you know well that's
the thing too I don't understand like I
said I don't wanna
put anything past him but
he
anybody who support him
should also understand why this is an
issue yeah why it's very hurtful once
again the Holocaust was not that [ __ ]
long ago and the rhetoric that he's
using now like you said was used
to exterminate and whole ethnicity yeah
like this is some serious [ __ ] right and
there's people now who still feel those
sentiments that still feel like Jewish
people shouldn't be around so you know
people are like well that's not what he
meant that's great intent does matter a
lot right I do believe that but the
outcome also matters a lot as well
because I don't know somebody that's [ __ ]
Japanese could be like dude I'm gonna
start bombing on all these Korean people
yeah and there might be a few creamy
like hey yo yeah
during the World Cup like hey hey man
relax yeah we're gonna [ __ ] go in the
world cup and start taking some [ __ ]
Koreans captive it's like okay World Cup
or world war three bro
you know and it's gonna make a certain
people feel a certain way because
there's people who live through this
type of stuff and so like I said okay I
know people have their reasons for
supporting continent because they have
Phantom they love them to death yeah by
the way he just posted something on uh
Instagram recently uh explaining his
relationship with Adidas and the
ownership of Yeezy right if people
really didn't [ __ ] with him
right why did that [ __ ] post have 603
000 likes last time I checked you really
think that you're gonna stop Kanye yeah
you're not gonna stop him from [ __ ] yeah
he's you're proving his point
capitalism rules everything clout rules
everything because he is the biggest
talked about thing right now even when
it's quote unquote negative everybody
still wants to buy the [ __ ] he's selling
and all of you are doing it he can make
like [ __ ] Supermarket flip-flops you
know people will [ __ ] copy that
people will buy this [ __ ] it'll be
limited yeah who knows Kanye might end
up dead next week and then everything
that we have with Kanye stuff is going
to be worth I own
two pairs of Yeezys yeah yeah I mean one
of the most comfortable shoes I've ever
worn in my [ __ ] life am I gonna stop
wearing them no I already bought them
yeah I already bought them I'm so like I
wanted to go back like because we were
also talking about the current state of
what shit's at like
um
after World War II there were
reparations
and
somehow like it's so complicated like
all the Allied countries and whatever
agreed to give them a parcel of land
Israel and they called it Israel
so before that there was no Israel it
had been sacked so many times it was
just Palestine now yeah you know and
they gave him a piece of land you know
in there and to call Israel and it was a
settlement for
all these uh Holocaust Survivors and
Jews from all over around the world to
hey come home you know we have this
man uh [ __ ] like 60 years later seven
years later oh man it's a become a [ __ ]
show because so that's that so that land
that they recollected and called Israel
is where people are saying you need to
get out of this [ __ ] wind yeah so a
lot of
uh like the Muslim nations around that
that's why they hate Israel
because they they were saying you stole
that land but what's happening over the
last so many decades has been years of
war against Palestinians and the
Israelites living there
but
gotta say because they had so many
billions of backing from different
European nations and especially America
um they've become super modernized
especially militarily
and so um they've expanded their borders
Way Beyond The Pale like
where it's basically apartheid now
Palestine has become now become the
smaller Island but there were millions
of people and now they're like crammed
and stuck in these homes and as of today
they're like
the Israeli government is just going to
Palestinian homes and evicting them just
kicking them out and throwing some
Jewish Family in there just to live
there
announce their home
and this is so complicated yeah it's
[ __ ] up but it's straight up apartheid
what's the the most [ __ ] up part about
it wow what Connie said was [ __ ] up
like what they're doing out there in
Israel like if you want to take on that
same philosophy of not generalizing them
like the Jewish people aren't the
problem right
but the Israeli government is a huge
problem yeah it's just so complicated
it's like
it almost feels
that the Israeli government's like I'm
gonna get you back for what you did
like you kick this out you kick this out
yeah we're going back
this is so it's so sad man like I was
when I was watching these videos and
once again this is somebody from an
outsider perspective who's just watching
Clips so once again I don't know
anything yeah so you know take
everything that we're saying here with
the grain of salt read everything
yourself yeah yeah you know but yeah we
were watching this thing and there was a
guy who was like reciting like Prophecy
with I don't know if it was from the
Quran or something man and he was like
we're going to kill you and I was like
what
I didn't know what this [ __ ] is you know
I mean I don't think it was from the
crown I don't know if he's this guy's
just making his [ __ ] up once again one
don't take everything what I'm saying
with the grain of salt I'm only watching
this from a clip and he's screaming at
him saying like I don't I think the clip
was him saying he was basically saying
hello to him
but he was he was said something back
but it wasn't hello or something else
because he's not allowed to greet
someone who was Jewish
like even in I don't know what if that's
religious or if that's cultural or
whatever but this is where this you know
argument started in a spark yeah this
could obviously be a propaganda page two
I don't really know but it got me into
like kind of semi-reading what's going
on which kind of touched on a lot of
stuff that you're actually digging into
right now which it's just a lot more
complicated than I I I I I knew about
you want you want to get even more
complicated
like one of the main reasons why
like Evangelical Americans care so much
about this too
like
they basically want this to happen they
want
our government to keep providing support
for the state of Israel
because it's going to bring the end of
the world
what the [ __ ] the Book of Revelations
dude the New Jerusalem
or Jerusalem where the the Temple of
Solomon would be rebuilt
it started when
the Jewish people like got Israel got
the reparations all these [ __ ] end
time crazy nuts saw that as the
beginning of the end
you know
uh and so like this is so they're saying
like yeah holy war is coming they're
saying all those crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
growing up in a Christian household
hearing that [ __ ] creeps me the [ __ ] out
yeah because we've heard about this so
many so many times growing up like the
end of times and you know a lot and the
reason why this also creeps me out is
because
um a lot of hardcore hardcore uh
religious like Zealot Fanatics yeah
um of Christianity are also kind of
really getting into well look at now gay
marriage is allowed
um there's this conversation about uh
gender reassignment and you know not
understand uh you know what is a man
what is a woman yeah and they're like
and now we have this the holy war going
on like the end of time is coming like
in the next like 20 years yeah and I'm
like what the [ __ ] man
like why is it the end of the world
though yeah
cool like you really can't handle change
that bad too gay folk been around for a
long last time yeah they've been around
[ __ ] since way before Sodom and Gomorrah
Yeah man they be [ __ ] dude yeah so um
might be wrong there dude but just
growing up with all this type of [ __ ]
always makes me makes my hair stand up a
little bit well like for me and like the
the amount that I did learn about
Revelation like when I was learning
Theology and [ __ ] too
like really getting down to the basics
of it who wrote it was the assuming the
same person who wrote the Book of John
who also claims to be John the disciple
of Jesus who was the youngest disciple
like he might have been 16 years old
right while everyone else was like in
their 20s and 30s which means like when
you're a disciple and you're like that
young like they're saying like he was a
really smart bright kid you know like
very smart guy
and
um
I guess the story goes that
the decades after Jesus's death the
persecution of Christians happened and
basically they were killing them right
uh Nero was killing them as Caesar at
the time um for sport in the Coliseum
they feed them to lions and like
Gladiators kill them and [ __ ]
um because that he was so against
Christianity so Nero was this crazy
[ __ ] Emperor who was the kind of guy
who split his mom open so he could see
where oh that's right yeah yeah yeah he
he it's widely believed that he's the
one that burned down half a room when
the The Story Goes that he played a
flute while it burned down and sing a
song so this guy's a crazy [ __ ]
and when Rome burned down he blamed it
on the Christians you know this is the
first century of Christianity by the way
yeah so this is early early days so The
Story Goes that they captured John
and they try to boil him in a vat of
acid at the coliseum in front of
thousands of people
they had a fan of acid like not acid oil
boiling and they threw him in there and
he would not burn you just chilled like
in an oil bath
you know and he wouldn't die and so for
that
they put him onto Exile onto this island
you know
and um from there he's writing these
letters just like Paul was that Paul
writes all these letters while he's in
jail he's so funny somebody just forgot
to light the oil yeah it was just cold
it's just cold oil hey guys yeah it's a
little thick
he's got a cold in here man
anointed but yeah uh so he's writing the
The Book of John and then first John
second John and I think something else
too and then he writes the book of
Revelations
and as he's writing these letters though
and he's saying these things about the
Beast of Babylon and about the New
Jerusalem and all these things and the
horror of Israel all these things
they're coded messages and like his
number would be 666. right and you got
to see this and one part of me just
believes there were these special
mushrooms that grew on that island and
he had a wild trip and he just wrote
about it and sent it to his friends you
know or he was in exiled he was going
[ __ ] insane yeah or
um he's an exile he's on the Roman guard
they're gonna read his [ __ ] letters
if he's talking [ __ ] yeah right and
there there are a lot of theologians who
explained like yeah the the Beast like
666. it's apparently it's not 666 a
rabbi actually told me that oh really
yeah he's like it's 666. and another
theological cell number yeah
what it is that like the Hebrew language
while it's they have their alphabetical
ones it's also numerical at the same
time so a number will represent an
alphabet right so you can have a numeric
code and it would be a word
and so apparently
666 also equals like Nero Caesar
right he's talking about Nero and all
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] he's doing oh and
he's burning what he's burning down and
all that saying like look this there is
an enemy and this is the Antichrist and
he started naming all these qualities of
Nero
you know but if you start talking [ __ ]
about Nero while they already try to
[ __ ] boil you [ __ ] oil yeah it's
like that let me you know write a code
into it yeah
basically what he was saying when he's
saying the end of the world like dude in
the year 70 A.D
you think they knew what the [ __ ] was
east of India yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know maybe they did yeah a few of them
but not really do you think they knew
there was another continent on the other
side of the ocean
you know what was the ends of the Earth
the Roman Empire yeah yeah yeah what was
the end of the world the Roman Empire
yeah he's just saying yo this is it this
is how the Empire goes down that's
fascinating you know that is crazy yeah
Doug so the end of the world happened
okay it [ __ ] happened 2 000 years
later oh dude that theory is so
interesting yeah and very sound very
sound you know what's so fascinating I'm
throwing some mushrooms might make more
sense than yeah because speaking of
mushrooms I only recently read up about
the Super Mario mushroom
hmm you know the you know the Toadstool
you know toad right yeah yeah he's that
is an actual mushroom that's a
psychedelic that grows out in like the
Netherlands okay like in the cold area
so
guess what else is red and white that we
celebrate every Christmas in a cold area
Santa Claus Santa Claus is is theorized
to be
a hallucinogen hallucinogenic thing that
happened when people would take this
mushroom Santa Claus is that mushroom so
what they found out
and this is true so reindeers out like
in the Netherlands I could be wrong
about that but you know those cold
Norwegian countries right yeah Rainier
actually eat that mushroom and they eat
it because of the psychedelic trip that
they have okay so when they eat it they
they go into a psychedelic trip to the
point where there were Native people
there that would actually collect the
Pea of reindeer and drink it for the
Psychedelic effect and then every every
time they would pee like the the native
people would pee yeah the the deer
because they're so addicted to the
psychedelics would try to go ahead and
drink them or the pee that they drank
the circle exactly so it's actually
believed that Santa Claus was a mushroom
thought you were gonna say that like
these reindeer like grew like twice
their size because there's a Super Mario
mushroom yeah so yeah it's believed that
Santa Claus is actually a a mushroom
which is [ __ ] trippy yeah why do they
call him Saint Nick
I have no idea oh I think I think it was
just like like religious cultures taking
over for that kind of [ __ ] too yeah yeah
yeah like you know like because
apparently actual Saint Nick the
historical figure was like a 300 580
Apostle or some [ __ ] oh okay he's known
for like punching some guy in the face
because he said Jesus wasn't God you
know oh wow so that's that's the most I
know of Saint Nick but I didn't know
like that was like Santa Claus yeah
there's like all these like weird
theories too there's like theories about
mushrooms being involved in the
invention of like Christianity too and
like Jesus Christ I think with like
Moses and the burning bush yeah that
sounds like it's like a trip to me yeah
um like all these other prophets who
have these crazy ass Visions dreams like
Isaiah
that you just told me is [ __ ]
fascinating 666 yeah 666 that is
fascinating as [ __ ] because you know as
growing up a Christian like have you
heard of uh left behind
no it's uh it was a book series and then
like Kirk Cameron starred in these
Christian movies where the Rapture
happens and then it's about life after
the Rapture like a church would have
movies nights and watch that [ __ ] but
then at the same time the idea of the
Rapture would freak me out too right and
I lived with a lot of that freak out
you know well into my mid-20s
in my face I mean we would live in
constant fear yeah like because they
would always say God is a loving God now
why the [ __ ] am I so scared of him all
the time yeah but no it's like basically
but but I had to confront with my like
whole idea of Faith too like
yeah am I supposed to be afraid of God
like scared of him and then I learned
the difference like the fear of God what
does that actually mean like deep down
in your heart compared to like the fear
of devils or some [ __ ] is like only skin
deep yeah you know and it helped me
learn to shake that kind of [ __ ] off but
at the same time like as I learn more on
like Theology and also more practical
ideas of looking at scripture too that
anxiety went away especially if I could
say yeah their interpretation of the end
of the world has happened
you know yeah and I don't have to freak
out about that then I also learned like
a lot of theologians and pastors don't
even believe in the rapture and neither
do I I think it's just [ __ ] it's
just a terrible interpretation of the
Bible basically it's I learned that it
was it was from a New York Times article
of all places that it was founded only
200 years ago this idea oh really yeah
that's what makes me know it's [ __ ]
and then they talked about the guy who
founded the idea he was like bedridden
for three years or some [ __ ] or so many
months or something right what what
happens to you when you're bedridden
like that you're depressed and you're
cynical
and he started like he was a theologian
but then he started he only read the
Bible while he was Bradford and I guess
he read it through hundreds of times and
just saw this [ __ ] like oh Jesus is
going to come back and everyone's gonna
disappear like all the righteous ones
and to be honest I just think it's
[ __ ] like so if you're a Christian
out there man just question your pastor
about that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah don't let
that [ __ ] ruin your life and your whole
faith I mean even a lot of the times too
like people who go into Christianity who
who do end up being in places of like
leadership they probably don't even go
as far as to look into this too because
theology takes time yeah and you know
just like anything else like when you go
through any type of education just
because you went to college doesn't mean
you were a smart person just because you
went to Seminary school doesn't mean you
were paying attention yeah means that
you probably enjoyed the community
aspect of being a pastor being a leader
but did you really really care to read
Theology and sit there and you know
Ponder these things question your faith
a lot of people don't do they don't do
that and we we talked about this too
it's a very sad thing with somebody who
is so prophetic and uh would profess
their love for Christ and God and
everything else but somebody who was
atheist knows more about the Bible than
you do and we see that a lot because the
reason why is because they're
questioning things and when you question
things you have a thirst for knowledge
yeah and you should have that same type
of knowledge if you are Christian I
truly do believe that right yeah but the
problem with like the way we're taught
about our faith
um that may not even be biblical
actually it could be but the idea is
that like when a challenge comes at your
door when an existential threat an
existential crisis knocks on your door a
lot of Christians will double down on
their faith which essentially means
going into your own bias
yeah
right yeah and what you believe and what
you know now here's the thing whatever
decisions you choose to make all based
on that bias we don't know great things
might happen bad things might happen
right but once you come out of that muck
which you eventually will like many
things in life
stronger from it too as well a lot of
Christians give that up to God right but
then it's like
you're you didn't even take the chance
you know
to question you know these things like
to ask yourself the right questions
about your faith instead of just diving
deep down into you know whatever your
already biases is yeah and that's
exactly what Kanye does yeah yeah yeah
through all of the [ __ ] he's ever
said
what if what has happened to his career
growth yeah exponential growth
ridiculous growth so no matter what he
said or done we all know he has a
massive massive ego right and he keeps
feeding into it into his own bias
Because he believes in himself that much
yeah and guess what he's been he proved
himself right every time for most
decades yeah yeah multiple times which
is why he is now such a huge egomaniac
and why he still believes in himself he
looks at himself he's a prophet Yeah
Yeah a hundred percent and people are
still buying into it that's what I said
multiple times on this podcast already
you guys are always going to buy into a
[ __ ] but like you said
that when the way you speak about how a
lot of pastors don't really prod into
their own theology
to this
anti-Semitism [ __ ] is like stuff that he
also seemed to have skipped yeah because
that conversation with Lex Friedman he
just really doesn't understand like
what anti-Semitism well I mean every
time somebody asks him a question he
responded with some obscure answer that
has nothing to do with the thing that's
being asked and it goes off into a
tangent about abortion about how hot Kim
Kardashian is I was like do you
understand what you've done
how can I hate Jews when blacks are Jews
yeah all right could you could you would
you care to expound upon this and he
just goes on a tangent I was I had
liposuction
[Laughter]
that's what happened to conversation
with this guy is damn near impossible
you might as well just talk to a [ __ ]
wall that just screams at you yeah like
it's just not gonna be normal you're not
gonna get us that what you think you
need to hear yeah you're trying to
rationalize with somebody who hasn't who
has an irrational bone in his body and
it's just not going to happen so yeah
you know conclusively just to end this
podcast
do I follow Kanye do I support him
absolutely not not after this year a lot
of stuff that he's done that's just been
very very damaging to not only his
community but just to people in general
and because he won't take responsibility
for it you know I I love his music his
music did a lot of [ __ ] for me man like
I love his music it's not going to take
away from those memories but it's hard
to say going forward that I care to hear
anything that he's going to say he's not
on the R Kelly level [ __ ] right yeah
like I just don't care for any of his
opinions I don't care for any of his
thoughts and you know I probably won't
be listening to any of his new music
um just because I'm trying to be about
what I say so it's like it is what it is
you know what I mean like my best friend
stopped listening to him after the whole
black lives matter thing and yeah he
still hasn't listened to his music since
right he was saying like uh black people
chose to be slaves yeah there's just a
lot of things and you know people are
like oh let me this is what he really
meant okay Andrew Tate yeah so you're
trying to explain what he really meant
versus what he said
and then the effect that came from that
yeah and the issue is it's like look at
what came from this right and if you
said it you should also accept the
responsibility for the things that
you're going to say if Kanye is not
taking responsibility you don't need to
be his apologist exactly yeah if he's
not accepting it why are you making
excuses for him yeah so it is what it is
all right guys well that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast
sometimes funny sometimes very
informational I learned a lot of new
[ __ ] yeah the end of world's not
happening guys it already happened so uh
you can catch at edparkvp on Instagram
at geniusbrain every Sundays at 12 p.m
uh secret society has her fall line out
coming soon
um so make sure that you guys cop that
have a happy happy Halloween everybody
or a happy Hallelujah Night
dude imagine some [ __ ] kid who is so
bored and he's there at the Hallelujah
Night it's like let me listen to some
David so we're [ __ ] clowning on
hallelujah oh [ __ ] uh we'll catch you
all next time every Sundays at 12 p.m
peace peace